you know if you're in high school now if
you're 16 years old you basically don't
work
um you know what what went into that why
did those jobs disappear part of the
answer has to do I believe with the idea
that we think the lower rungs on the
latter are somehow less important part
of it has to do with the conversation
we've heard around like the minimum wage
right and so many arguments that attempt
to take an entry-level job that was
never designed to generate enough income
to support you
and and and belittle that opportunity
because it's not
a higher rung right and so we we just
entered into this space I think where we
wanted all of the rungs on the ladder to
be absolutely equal